i'm
23 years old and sometimes i wonder if
life was wasted on me
[Music]
i take all the beautiful things to heart
until i about die from it
[Music]
hey i'm really happy you're here why is
that
because i like you but there never seems
i joined the army why would you do that
sometimes i feel like i've already seen
everything that's gonna happen
and it's a nightmare
[Music]
my one true accomplishment was not dying
[Music]
i have this noise in my head it'll stop
one day it'll go quiet i don't imagine
that anyone goes in for a robbery if
they're not in some kind of desperation
i've been at this a while now and it's
no secret what my face looks like
get on the ground one thing about
robbing banks is you're mostly robbing
women so the last thing you want to be
is rude
ma'am it's nothing personal
[Music]
you're gonna make it through this i love
you
can you look back to when you met the
one you loved the most
you remember exactly how it was
what you saw in her that made you say
yes this is what i came here for
sometimes i feel like i've already seen
everything that's gonna happen
and it's a nightmare
you